Elizabeth Chambers is opening up about
the end of her decade-long marriage with
Army Hammer the disgraced actor became
the center of abuse and sexual assault
allegations just six months after they
separated trigger warning as this story
involves stories of sexual violence in
an intimate interview with L magazine
Elizabeth details the crumbling of their
marriage revealing that the final straw
was Army's decision to leave her and
their two children behind in the Cayman
Islands to return to California at the
beginning of the covid-19 pandemic she
tells the Meg my heart was broken in
nine million pieces and I still drove
him to the airport
Elizabeth also shares that the
allegations of her ex's infidelity and
fetishes including bondage and violence
in the bedroom were things she learned
while alone in the Cayman Islands
stating I was learning things as the
public was there are no words in July
2020 the couple announced in a joint
Instagram post that they would be
separating while Elizabeth sang she's
learned to heal and grow since the split
while still supporting Army as they
learn to co-parent she tells Elle I
support Army through his journey and I
always will all I've ever wanted is for
him to be sober healthy and happy and he
is that he's really present when he's
with the kids and that's all I can hope
for meanwhile in January 2021 Army's
alleged text messages to various women
were released online detailing his
alleged BDSM and cannibalistic fantasies
the actor was also accused of abusive
behavior and sexual misconduct leading
the LAPD to launch an investigation and
two years later Army breaks his silence
on the allegations revealing to air mail
that his behavior stems from being a
victim of child sexual abuse stating it
introduced sexuality into my life in a
way that it was completely out of my
control I was powerless in the situation
I had no agency in the situation
sexuality was introduced to me in a
scary way
when asked if he was emotionally abusive
to the women who have accused him Army
admits one million percent I'm here to
own my mistakes take accountability for
the fact that I was an a-hole that I was
selfish that I used people to make me
feel better and when I was done moved on